[Musica]
Se guardiamo ad occhio nudo il cielo
stellato e tracciamo delle linee
immaginarie potremmo riconoscere le
costellazioni e risse associare dei
giganteschi personaggi che hanno
tracciato e ispirato quei miti che hanno
formato la cosmogonia la prima
interpretazione
mitica del destino del nostro Cosmo il
primo modello di riferimento di del
nostro Cosmo Di come di come evolve e
insieme con lui evolve il destino
dell'uomo
questa cosmogonia che in realtà adesso è
associata all'astrologia è uno dei punti
cruciali che ha
spinto avanti anche l'astronomia lo
sviluppo dell'astronomia moderna
tipo Bra era un astrologo
l'astrologo che spinto dalla passione
dell'astrologia ha sviluppato delle
misure straordinariamente precise senza
l'utilizzo di strumenti
e
nonostante aver ritrovato delle
imperfezioni nello sviluppo del modello
tolemaico che vede la terra al centro
del Cosmo e il modello dominante di quel
tempo
e ha insistito ad essere in una
posizione
di Forte oppositore al Moderno
copernicano bisogna aspettare l'arrivo
del suo discepolo il Keplero
che
interpreta queste misure
e nell'interpretazione di queste misure
fa sì di rendersi conto che il modello
più semplice è quello di porre il sole
al centro con i pianeti che girano
attorno enuncia le tre famose leggi di
Keplero l'ultima delle quali è enunciata
nel
1614 ed è la legge che spiana la strada
alla prima teoria completa della
gravitazione di Newton quindi
le misure di astrologia sono quelle che
hanno spinto alla nascita
dell'astronomia moderna sono le misure
sono gli strumenti che ci fanno avanzare
nella nostra continua ricerca di capire
come Il cosmo
diviene come quali siano le leggi
fondamentali del Cosmo Galileo
apprende dell'esistenza del cannocchiale
ne costruisce uno lo punta verso il
cielo e nel puntarlo verso il cielo si
rende conto che quelle che si vedono a
occhio nudo le ombre che si vedono
occhio nudo sulla luna non sono ombre
sono
le linee che segnano l'esistenza di
montagne e crateri sulla luna
sono
la nuova visione che si apre sul Cosmo
che fino Allora era limitato dalle
capacità di visione dell'occhio nudo
Questo è quello che è avvenuto Queste
sono le immagini dei disegni di Galileo
e accanto vedete il salto delle immagini
ottenute con il telescopio spaziale
moderno
le leggi di Keplero Sono alla base della
grande sintesi della prima teoria della
gravitazione che la teoria di Newton
Newton enuncia la sua teoria della
gravitazione universale
anch'esso un elemento di grande
rivoluzione culturale perché è una legge
che spiega il moto dei pianeti ma spiega
anche le traiettorie dei proiettili
quindi unifica in un processo mentale
formidabile le leggi della terra con le
leggi del cielo
per Newton
la
i concetti quali tempo e spazio sono
concetti che hanno una valenza assoluta
sono concetti
separati tra di loro e nei suoi principi
questo diventa un un'assunzione che
permane nel tempo e Domina la scienza
fino all'inizio del Novecento
il grande cambiamento avviene con
Albert Einstein già nel 1905 quando
enuncia la relatività ristretta in
questa nuova teoria
quello che accade e che spazio e tempo
diventano dei concetti non più
immutabili le misure di spazio e tempo
dipendono dalla moto relativo
dell'osservatore il tempo rallenta le
lunghezze si contraggono
quindi spazio e tempo sono concetti che
si mescolano tra di loro già a livello
della Natività ristretta e lo stesso
Einstein più tardi che
introduce nei suoi concetti
associa alla relatività la gravitazione
la gravitazione significa introdurre le
forze di interazione tra corpi e il
ruolo della materia
Questa teoria è una teoria che di nuovo
spiega nel Massimo dettaglio il
movimento dei pianeti ma anche illustra
e quantifica l'effetto di deviazione
della traiettoria della luce che passa
in prossimità dei corpi
Questo è il cosiddetto effetto di lente
gravitazionale
ed è un ruolo fondamentale nella teoria
perché seguire la traiettoria della luce
significa
andare a studiare la proprietà dello
spazio in questa teoria
quindi le linee della luce si incurvano
lo spazio si incurva e il tempo rallenta
in prossimità delle masse qui in questa
teoria
materia spazio e tempo sono uniti
insieme Questa teoria è una teoria
matematica che è una matematica
piuttosto complessa e la matematica
piuttosto complessa
ha impedito la diffusione sistematica di
queste di questa teoria alla nella prima
metà del secolo del Novecento Questa
teoria
faceva delle previsioni su effetti che
erano effetti molto deboli
e per affermarsi Come teoria nuova e
assoluta e di riferimento per
l'interpretazione degli fenomeni
gravitazionali bisogna attendere il
grande sviluppo tecnologico della
seconda parte del Novecento in questo
caso quello che accade con lo sviluppo
tecnologico e i nuovi strumenti
si accumulano le
osservazioni sperimentali a supporto di
questa teoria e il riferimento Ormai per
l'interpretazione dei fenomeni
gravitazionali è la relatività di Albert
Einstein e con essa un nuovo modello del
Cosmo di un Cosmo in divenire si
affaccia e si presenta dominante nella
negli ambienti scientifici
nella teoria di Einstein ciò che accade
è che lo spazio tempo viene
rappresentato come un tessuto
è un tessuto la cui struttura le cui
proprietà dipendono la tale
distribuzione delle masse lo spazio
tempo attorno a queste masse si piega si
contrae e si allunga e se queste masse
accelerano queste pieghe dello spazio
tempo si propagano in tutto l'universo
così come accade quando noi lanciamo un
sasso nello stagno
l'immagine che abbiamo dell'universo
almeno fino al 2015 è l'immagine
ottenuta attraverso le informazioni che
sono trasportate
dalla radiazioni elettromagnetiche Noi
abbiamo l'immagine dell'universo
ottenuta Osservando i fenomeni che
emettono raggi x onde radio in primis la
luce la luce proveniente dalle stelle
questa immagine
dell'universo
è l'immagine di riferimento per capire
quali siano le leggi che dominano
l'evoluzione dell'universo
oggi
si è aperto un nuovo canale di
informazione
si è aperto il canale delle onde
gravitazionali le onde gravitazionali
riescono a farci vedere il lato oscuro
dell'universo tutti quei fenomeni che
non emettono radiazione luminosa
Nel febbraio del 2016 è stata annunciata
la scoperta del primo segnale
gravitazionale una scoperta che ha avuto
un larghissimo eco anche qui a Vicenza
della
rivelazione del segnale gravitazionale e
a fronte di questo grande successo
i premi Nobel sono stati assegnati a Ray
wise paribarice Keep Thorne per questo
grande successo scientifico si è
trattata di un'impresa tecnologica
veramente imponente qui dobbiamo
rivelare una variazione di distanza che
è dell'ordine di 10 alla meno 19 metri
Cosa significa praticamente dobbiamo
vedere una variazione di una quantità
che è un decimillesimo del diametro di
un nucleo
10.000 volte più piccolo
di una variazione pari ad un metro della
distanza tra la Terra e il Sole abbiamo
messo a punto uno strumento sensazionale
si tratta di un interferometro di
michaelson in cui la luce che è generata
da un laser estremamente stabile
viene Separata in due fasci che si
propagano avanti e dietro e poi
rimbalzano su Degli Specchi perfetti
quasi perfetti si ricombinano e poi
interferiscono e quando ri
interferiscono Noi abbiamo
l'informazione che
nella comparare le distanze percorse dai
raggi sia arrivata l'onda gravitazionale
la grande difficoltà è estrarre questa
informazione
da un numerose sorgenti di rumore che
tendono a mascherare questa variazione
piccolissima di distanza ed è per questo
che abbiamo sviluppato tecnologie più
raffinate mettendo insieme esperti
di tutto il mondo
delle materie più disperate esperti di
ottica di meccanica di elettronica
esperti di robotica esperti di
sosmologia
Questa è la foto dei rivelatori che
hanno partecipato a questo grande
sviluppo scientifico che è andato avanti
per circa 50 anni prima di arrivare al
successo
decretato dalla prima scoperta del
segnale
e questo successo è dovuto non solo alle
tre persone che hanno preso il Nobel ma
soprattutto ha una collaborazione
internazionale
molto vasta distribuita su quattro
continenti è una collaborazione formata
da persone
di estrazione culturale La più diversa
hanno lavorato insieme senza
alcuna
separazione dovuta a differenze di sesso
di razza di religione
tutti tesi al grande scopo di capire
fino in fondo quali fossero le leggi
profonde che governano l'evoluzione
dell'universo allo scopo di rivelare il
lato oscuro dell'universo
che con le onde gravitazionali dovremmo
riuscire a mettere in evidenza è un
nuovo passo in avanti un nuovo modo di
rappresentare il Cosmo e in questo senso
la gravità e le onde gravitazionali
potranno dare un contributo fondamentale
per farci avanzare nella esplorazione
dell'universo nel capire fino in fondo
quali siano le leggi che governano la
sua evoluzione
e consentire a noi di vivere Quindi con
Maggiore coscienza
e in maggiore Armonia con la natura e Il
cosmo che ci circonda Grazie
[Applauso]